alors qu'Israël a progressivement repris
le contrôle et sécurisé les zones
frontalières avec la bande de Gaza que
les terroristes avaient infiltré
l'ampleur du massacre perpétré par le
Hamas a été révélé il s'agit d'une
attaque meurtrière et barbare rappelant
le modus operandi de l'État islamique
initié par des organisations terroristes
dirigées par le Hamas une attaque lancée
sans aucun prétexte légitime ni action
provocative préalable de la part
d'Israël cette attaque révèle une fois
de plus le vrai visage de ces
organisations terroristes à savoir des
groupes sanguinaires et incontrôlables
issus de la même branche que l'État
islamique dépourvu de toute inhibition
morale motivé par la haine et le désir
de blesser les citoyens israéliens par
tous les moyens et provoquer la
destruction de l'État
d'Israël il est à rappeler que le Hamas
ne se préoccupe pas de la sécurité ou du
bien-être de sa population civile dans
la bande de Gaza il ne les considère que
comme des pions à exploiter dans ses
efforts pour nuire aux citoyens
israéliens à ce jour nous pleurons plus
de 1400 civils assassinés parmi lesquels
des bébés des enfants des femmes et des
personnes âgées et même des rescapés de
la
choix les plans du Hamas retrouvés sur
les corps des terroristes prouvent que
le Hamas avait par parfaitement planifié
la mort et la prise d'otage de civils en
ciblant intentionnellement les femmes et
les enfants des familles entières ont
été décimé dans leur maison environ 260
jeunes ont été abattus lors d'un
festival de musique au moins 3500
personnes ont été blessées et beaucoup
aile encore entre la vie et la mort on
décomte 199 personnes kidnappé vers Gaza
de 43 nationalités différentes sans que
l'on connaît leur sort